i was on a flight to russia it turned
out to be the scariest flight of my
entire life
this is that story at the time i was
living in russia and i was flying back
home from a winter in the u.s
i didn't want to fly for multiple
reasons first all flights were canceled
because of a volcano
that exploded in iceland and the ash
made it dangerous to fly so we were one
of the first flights to be allowed to
fly over iceland and
well didn't sound safe second i just
watched the first episode of lost so i
now know that planes can be split in
half people get sucked out
i don't want to fly to be honest i've
been terrified of flying ever since i
was a little kid my mom freaks out on
planes so i guess some of it may be
rubbed off on me she does that thing
where she grabs the seat handles with
all her force which is
not that much and she just holds on so
the day came when it was time for me to
fly back to russia when we got to the
airport i was begging my mom to cancel
the flight and go home i had a terrible
feeling about this flight and i know i
have terrible feelings about all flights
but this time
it was terriblier but we had to get home
so my mom grabbed my hand and dragged me
onto the plane i wasn't gonna give up
just yet though
i was determined to get off the plane
i'd have thought
i was recently just watching x-men i was
watching a lot of things okay
maybe just maybe i could use my brain
to break the plane so i warned my mom
i'm gonna break the plane with my brain
she ignored me so i put my fingers to my
temples and concentrated
30 minutes go by we've left the gate and
we're just taxing around the runway
suddenly the pilot comes over the
intercom and says we need to go back to
the gate
we had to switch planes because there
was an issue with the wheel i did it
i broke the plane with my brain my mom's
trying to figure out if she has some
sort of x-men kid i'm trying to figure
out what to do with my newfound powers
so yeah thanks for watching this is my
story i have super power just kidding
there was another plane
unfortunately my powers weren't enough
this time we taxied sped up
and we're flying so i look out the
window and we're literally
flying we're in the air there's nothing
there's nothing under us i don't
understand how this is
i'm just in a metal object so i'm trying
to calm myself down i get comfortable in
the seat i start sifting through the
little seat pocket
i'm so bored i grab the safety manual
i'm seeing people with their head
between their knees
life jackets like raft boats water
slides and
spoiler alert you're supposed to put on
your own oxygen mask before you help
others
i can't keep reading this it's starting
to scare me again so i decided to go to
sleep to avoid all my problems because
if anything happened i could just sleep
through
it so i passed out
all of a sudden i wake up the plane is
shaking
people are crying all the lights are out
holy sh what the [ __ ] is going on
stewardesses are running around with
flashlights in a panic
this is lost i was like mom what's going
on please tell me what's going on she
looks at me in full panic eric
go to sleep go to sleep so i'm trying to
figure out what's going on and i look
out the window
and i see fire
[Music]
the wing of the plane is on fire so i
spring into action and immediately i
start
crying i thought i was gonna die
and the worst part is i predicted this i
knew this was gonna be happening yeah i
got on the plane and now i'm on the
plane and now we're gonna crash and i'm
gonna die so the pilot comes over the
intercom again
there's a how do i say this
issue with the plane and we're gonna
have to do an emergency landing i'm not
a plane guy or anything but i think i
know what the problem is it's uh uh
we're uh we're on fire
also what's an emergency landing mean so
here's where she gets real
i look at the little tv in front of me
that sometimes has a little map on it
the little plane
it's got a little line and then you can
like see how much time you have left on
the flight it's just the atlantic ocean
everything is ocean
nothing but ocean ocean i remember
taking a deep breath and for some reason
the only thing i could think to do was
fly this plane myself i had been using
my powers for evil before but
now i'm gonna use them for good i don't
know why this made sense to me at the
time but i swear this is what happened
i grabbed the imaginary steering wheel
and put my foot
on the gas pedal i mean i don't know if
planes have gas pedals probably not but
this imaginary situation
did so i was flying the plane i was also
praying relentlessly i remember
promising god that i would never cheat
on a spelling test again
i don't know how to fly a plane we're
gonna land in the ocean i'm gonna have
to use that dumb water slide
now i'm doing that thing where i'm
clutching the armrest like my mom the
plane was dropping fast not like it was
falling out of the sky or anything but i
knew the pilot wanted to land
asap the closer we get to the ocean or
the earth or whatever i can see there's
an island
it's lost we're in the middle of the
atlantic ocean where is there an island
but
it's green and beautiful and we're
landing on it the plane lands just like
any other plane not like crashing to the
ground
or anything just a simple basic land we
all run off the plane as quickly as
possible as people in tin foil suits
enter the plane to stop the fire i was
looking around and
i couldn't believe my eyes none of this
looked real there was just a bunch of
rolling hills of lush farms
did i just crash land into a vacation to
give you an image this looks like where
the teletubbies live
turns out for all you geography fans out
there this was an island
within islands that was a part of
portugal collectively known as azorus
now that i was safe on the ground my
mind started reeling
what if we weren't near an island would
we would we have crashed into the ocean
whatever it's fine i'm alive it's fine
we ended up staying the night there and
then flying out on another plane the
next day
so finally after two and a half days we
landed in russia
the pilot apologized for the
inconvenience and
offered everybody gift cards
sorry the plane kind of crashed and like
caught fire but
we got gift cards if you're thinking
about leaving the video do not leave yet
because i haven't even gotten to the
craziest part of the story
so i go about my life as a near plane
crash survivor and
everything's going fine until my friend
sends me a video from ellen so what's
the scariest thing you've ever done
it's leonardo dicaprio telling a story
flying out of new york to russia i was
on a plane to russia
engine catches fire i was looking out
the window and the entire
engine just turned into a fireball
was leonardo dicaprio on the same flight
as me
leonardo dicaprio was on the same flight
as me we
we shared a plane we almost crashed
together oh my god we have so much to
talk about like what row were you in how
was that fire did you use the coupon yet
then i
come to learn we weren't on the same
flight his flight though oddly similar
landed back in nyc still that is [ __ ]
crazy that's an insane coincidence to
have with leonardo dicaprio is this a
common occurrence did i just waste
everybody's time
are you looking at me yeah why because
well apparently this isn't a very
original story
you told me this was a good story
it's over i'm sorry